en grandissant, je n'ai même jamais rêvé qu'il y avait
un enfant trans. J'allais un jour avoir une
belle femme. Je me sentais vraiment comme un
monstre en grandissant. Je pensais qu'il n'y avait
personne d'autre comme moi. Je pensais que
quelque chose n'allait vraiment pas chez moi
et c'était le cas.  J'avais donc 25 ans et j'ai même
vu un autre homme trans et j'ai en quelque sorte
réalisé qu'il y avait en fait d'autres
personnes comme moi et d'autres
personnes comme Ana. Je ne me suis jamais vraiment permis
de croire qu'il était possible de se
marier avec Jake en grandissant.  tout
semble si lointain si loin tu sais
la vie que je vivais ce n'était pas la
vie qui me convenait et j'ai
vraiment pensé que ce n'était jamais
possible d'y arriver et donc découvrir
avec Jake que c'était possible, c'était toi  je
sais que c'était comme naître de nouveau, c'était
magnifique
[Musique]
Je l'ai ajoutée sur Facebook en tant qu'amie et
puis environ une heure plus tard, elle m'a
répondu avec un petit message me
disant juste bonjour Jake, tu sais, je sais que nous l'
avons fait.  Je ne me suis pas rencontré mais j'ai regardé ce que
tu fais et je pense que c'est génial et
tu sais, avec un peu de chance, quand ils se rencontreront
et puis nous avons commencé à parler, notre premier
rendez-vous était mon premier rendez-vous
et donc j'étais assez nerveux à ce sujet mais
Jake l'était  vraiment, le monsieur, vous
savez, il a organisé un rendez-vous, il nous a
emmenés et vous savez que nous avons passé un très bon
moment
notre premier, ils l'ont perdu 11 heures donc je
pense que si un premier rendez-vous dure 11 heures
et que vous en voulez toujours plus, c'est
bon signe
[Musique]
J'ai toujours voulu me marier. Je suis
très traditionnel. J'étais l'un des enfants avec qui je suis
allé en tant que Manny, donc je me suis occupé des
enfants des autres pendant environ 20
ans. Je voulais juste une
épouse traditionnelle, les enfants.  tu sais, le sapin de Noël,
Noël, tu sais juste ces choses
qui, pour être honnête, je n'aurais jamais pensé
les avoir mais c'est ce que j'ai toujours
vraiment voulu, je pensais que nous voulions vraiment
montrer comme une histoire positive tant
d'histoires sur les
personnes transgenres  dans le contexte médiatique pour moi
en grandissant, c'était très très négatif, vous
savez, il s'agit surtout de
personnes trans malheureuses, battues et
assassinées et ce que nous voulions
montrer au monde, c'est qu'il est possible d'
être transgenre et heureux
[Musique]
mais  sache juste que tu sais que tu n'es pas
seul là-bas, qu'il y a un grand
nombre de gens comme nous, qu'il y a
leur force, leur unité et leur force dans le
nombre et je pense que tu l'as, tu
vas voir de plus en plus de gens comme toi.
si vous me demandiez il y a trois ans si j'étais
ici à côté d'un homme que j'aime marié et
regardant vers l'avenir
ensemble, j'aurais répondu que vous êtes
absolument fou, alors où que vous soyez
en ce moment, même si les choses semblent sombres, les
choses s'améliorent.